herzlich willkommen und einen
wunderschönen vormittag zum ersten
training der zweiten woche wir
trainieren heute mit euch ein
rumpfprogramm wir machen einen
rumpfkader in den rumpf kraft zirkel das
heißt unser hauptaugenmerk trainings
technisch wird auf der bauch- und
rückenmuskulatur liegen und wie bereits
letzte woche vor angekündigt wenn ihr
diesen beitrag teilt und kommentiert
nehmt ihr an der verlosung unserer
wasserflaschen mit teil
und ich glaube es ja ganz nette
erinnerung das heißt fleißig teilen und
kommentieren
wir trainieren heute zu dritt wieder die
nici der herbert und ich später leiten
und führen euch durch das programm
das neue gesicht der herbert bitte stell
dich ganz kurz vor hallo mein name ist
herbert hofer jetzt gerade offiziell
vertreter der unteroffizier im
sportzentrum meine sportlichen
schwergewichten legen im elektro fitness
eben krafttraining und im militärischen
boxen danke herbert nix gutes wochenende
gekommen
aber wir machen heute 30 sekunden
belastungs zeit 30 sekunden pause zeit
und die die es intensiver möchten machen
eine minute belastungs zeit ohne pause
dann geht es ist die rolle von kaymer ja
ganz gut aus die ecke wird euch die
intensive variante mit einer minute
durchgehend arbeiten zeigen und daher
wird die etwas lockere variante mit 30
wie gesagt fragen machen oder was
braucht man schon mal anfangen was
machen wir zu beginn bevor mein workout
einsteigen auf den walker hofmann genau
wie lassen am stand so wie fast jeden
tag und leute ihr wisst sich wiederhole
mich aber ich wiederhole mich in diesem
fall gerne
wir sind auch heute wieder mit einem
schnelltest corona getestet und wir sind
wieder alle negativ dass heißt auch
unser abstand ist wiederum kein problem
weil die arme dazu fordert dass wir die
zwei bewegungen kombinieren bis jetzt
haben wir ja nur losgelöst voneinander
gemacht und die wird merken
ihr müsst gleich aus dem bauch und aus
dem rücken heraus ganz anderer
stabilisieren als wir wenn man nur läuft
am start und rückwärts kreisen
wer kann kreist gegen gleich ja jetzt
schon kompliziert wie man den bauch
richtig anspannt das becken stabil
bleibt und damit kurz aus logen
okay wir nehmen einen gut hilft breiten
standfüße schulterbreit oberkörper in
der vorbeuge und wir drehen den umfang
der vorbeuge die übung kendzia schon
dass man entlang von der wirbelsäule
schön mobilisiert sein genau und erkennt
sie natürlich jederzeit während dessen
handy dann zur hand nehmen euch den
timer einstellen 30 30 oder eine minute
durch laufend also beide varianten
intensiv oder ein bisschen lockerer ist
möglich genau noch mal wieder am stand
ihr gesagt dass man die arme wieder
gleich dazu dass die entsprechend mit
dabei sein
und jetzt da immer mal das linke knie
hoch das heißt auf mein signal ihr lauf
zweiter ihr herz zu mir hat er versucht
das linke knie anzuheben dabei
wechsel auf das rechte knie
kerner und wieder ausloggen
wenn es nicht gerade mit den schritten
nicht ausgeht kann tragisch und schnelle
möglichkeit hochheben und nadal hatten
es kommt der rhythmus sondern einfach
zuhören und versuchen das umzusetzen
okay was kann man auf die klassische
aufgabe über machen mit was folgt ihr
ein haben wir mann zu bringen dass man
das herz kreislauf system in schwung
bringen genau fahren wir gerne mit dem
hampelmann springen und auch vor zurück
möglichst mit ausfallschritte genau sehr
gut und wieder ausland nehmen wir gleich
die nackenmuskulatur hier schauen wir
dass menschen umkommen kopf blick
wendung auf die linke seite und auf die
rechte seite im wechsel und dann bleiben
stabil oberkörper bleibt stabil
lediglich der kopf bewegt sich jetzt
dann gibt man greifen die linken auf die
rechte seite und dann braucht man auch
altkreise erkennt sie schauen auf die
linke seite mit dem kinn rollen über die
bis hin zur rechten seite
ok als virtuelle manchmal ganz heikel da
runter gehen wir mal die hände seitlich
hochdrehen den unterarm das heißt wir
rotieren die unterarme das
ellbogengelenk bislang dynamik
reinbringen richtung wechseln
ag und die arme ausloggen thema die
handgelenke zusammen und kreisen die
handgelenke erreichen wie gesagt 456
bewegungen pro richtung selbstständig
die richtung wechseln
genau und bewegen mal wieder am start
mal wieder anstand kreis mit die arme
wieder rückwärts dazu und jetzt da
manchmal links und rechts und wenn ich
selbst das linke knie und bei rechts ist
rechtlich nicht links rechts rechts
links links rechts und aus locker ja
aber okay becken kreisen hände am besten
in die hüfte hinein und einfach immer
mit kleinen kreisen beginnen und dann
immer größer werden
wer ganz groß die kreise bereits hat ja
so wie es bei denic jetzt ist die
erfahrung da an die richtung zu wechseln
wir beginnen damit den großen kreisen
und werden immer kleiner
und wir laufen wieder anstand geht schon
weiter und jetzt ganz gut aufpassen weil
es machen was umgekehrt
manni linksknick hilfst du das rechte
bein und waren die rechtslage hierzu das
linke bein
das heißt die schau mal dass man den
kopf an um mit ins boot holen okay
rechts rechts links links links rechts
links
da haben wir teilweise ein viertel brach
aus kann pasta war sehr gut wir schauen
einfach gesagt dass man locker das
herz-kreislauf-system in schwung bringen
okay wir haben den großteil haben
erledigt kniegelenk muss man da wieder
im einband stand so wie letzte woche das
heißt rechtes knie hoch heben wir können
das in einem rechten winkel hoch heben
wir können das auch über die höhe
darüber hier mode kennt das
herunterlassen
das ist nicht so tragisch je nachdem wie
gut trainiert euer gleichgewicht system
bereits ist und wir greifen den
unterschenkel genau und das andere bein
stabilisiert gleicht aus hält das
gleichgewicht die hände kann es
natürlich zum gleichgewicht jemand ja
mitnehmen können so sagen die umstellung
geben wie es bei der selbstverteidigung
und bei militärischen boxen davor ist
das noch schwieriger richtung wechseln
und bevor ich das bein ab feldmann
seitenwechsel andere seite richtung
wechseln
und wieder abstellen
okay aber bitte noch hand einspringen
und jetzt machen wir das herz kreislauf
system wirklich ein bisschen aktiver auf
start schneller werden und der stopp
wieder langsamer statt von stop & start
stopp und wieder ausloggen letztes
gelenk was man da brauchen wir der
aufwärtsphase mobilisieren ist das
sprunggelenk
wir haben wieder das rechte bein hoch
und kreisen im sprunggelenk genau 45 mal
richtung wechseln und seite wechseln
andere seite und richtung wechseln
genau so kurzes aufwärmprogramm
abgeschlossen jetzt wird es zeit dass
ein timer aktiviert okay das heißt die
die richtig gas geben wollen eine minute
im wechsel das ist immer eine minute
eine minute durch laufend und die das
lockerer angehen wohin machen 30 30
immer mit der 30 sekündigen pause dazu
ok ich gesagt wir fangen an mit der
ersten übung wird sagen wir haben wir
ganz kurz vor nicki darf die bieten den
unter anstoß für die die letzte woche
noch nicht dabei waren die wichtigen
punkte sind
ich muss spannung in der bauchmuskulatur
haben ich brauche zwischen der schulter
dem becken und im sprunggelenk ungefähr
eine gerade das heißt da hinten schaut
nicht zu weit nach oben zeigen vor wie
es nicht sein soll nicht genau und er
hängt dann nicht nach unten durch jawohl
super die unterarme sind annähernd
parallel unter kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule
diese punkte heute sein und dann geht's
los okay was kannst du uns einmal
entspannen
die zweite variante ist darunter ein
sturz mit dem kurzen hebel das heißt das
ganze wird am knie abgelegt das heißt
zwischen knie hüfte und schulter habe
ich die ebene auch hier ist der kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und dame
parallel und viel spannung aus der
bauchmuskulatur heraus seid bereit
erst war ich hoffe ihr zuhause auch das
heißt in drei sekunden staatenlos in 321
und los gehts 30 sekunden
beziehungsweise eine minute lang
arbeitszeit da ist wichtig für euch der
kopf bleibt stabil
das heißt der kopf schaut nicht nach
hinten schaut nach oben schaut nach
links oder rechts das heißt das thema
sollte immer im blick reichweite sein
oder ihr hört zu anfang auf mich ich
sage euch das an waren die zeit vorbei
ist ihr habt es nur fünf sekunden für
die 30 sekündige variante machen so 1
und aus ihr wird kurze pause
niki bleibt drauf das heißt sie bleibt
die ganze minute drauf das heißt
weiterarbeiten bitte und wir zeigen in
der zwischenzeit gleich die zweite übung
vor den holzhacker das heißt die beide
sind am boden da hinten ist angespannt
und die hände bewegen sich in der
vorhalle auf und ab wir können natürlich
mit dem tempo variieren
wichtig ist dass die brust abgelöst ist
vom boden das heißt dass ihr möglichst
viel spannung jetzt in der
rückenmuskulatur haben noch fünf
sekunden bereitmachen zum wechsel 21 uhr
los geht's
wem die übung jetzt in der
schultermuskulatur vom erhalten der arme
etwas zu schwierig wird er zwar mal vor
wenn der bislang winkel rhein gibt es
und die hände zurück schießt genau
wichtig ist dass eben die brust abgelöst
vom boden bleibt ja gibt es noch 13
sekunden wird halbzeit schon wieder gut
vorbei 5 halbzeit herbert wir nehmen
gleich die nächste übung das heißt wir
machen den seit stück auf der linken
seite mit dem kurzen hebel das heißt es
setzt der unterarm ist auf der matte das
becken ist losgelöst von der matte und
die knie schauen ihnen also der
unterschenkel schau die einen rechten
winkel ungefähr zum oberschenkel zurück
so hat es einen schönen kurzen hebel
das heißt die belastung auf der
bauchmuskulatur ist da aber nicht
überfordern
ok sie konnten dann geht schon wieder
los niki bereiten für ein wechsel
wechsel jetzt
und da hab zwar entsprechend die die
vorige woche schon fleißig mit dabei
waren ihr wisst es bereits alle anderen
noch einmal zum zum mithören zwischen
den beinen und dem oberkörper ist eine
gerade und das ist ganz wichtig der kopf
ist wiederum die verlängerung der
wirbelsäule und wir versucht die
spannung zu halten und dort probiert sei
das becken ganz leicht nach vor zu
drehen genau dann hat es richtig
eindruck auf der seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur 30 sekunden vorbei du
musst bleiben
durchbeißen hier wird nächste übung auf
der seite genau du kannst du den
oberkörper hinlegen da brauchst du gar
nicht abstützen und hebt die beine
gestreckt nach oben
gerne abheben und nach oben ziehen
eine etwas leichtere variante noch wenn
das abo zu schwierig ist genau wie
geht's die beine an und dann sieht das
nach oben fünf sekunden noch zeit nicht
geschafft die übung 21 und wechsel sehr
wichtig ist beine strecken und nach oben
ziehen
das spürt sie wiederum in der seitlichen
bauchmuskulatur zuerst auf der
unterseite beim stütz und jetzt auf der
oberen seite
das heißt in dem bereich solltet ihr die
übung spüren
spürbar spürst dass spätestens im
zweiten 32 kunden wird es dann richtig
spüren fünf sekunden hat es noch 21 ort
pause für die 30 sekunden variante jetzt
gehen wir in den unterarm stütz
rücklings das heißt der bauch und der
kopf schaut nach oben
das heißt die ellbogen sind wieder am
boden die unterarme der kopf ist wieder
in verlängerung der wirbelsäule das
heißt der blick geht nach oben
das becken ist schon angehoben genannt
er hat es wieder zwischen sprunggelenk
hüfte und schulter eine gerade während
es von der beweglichkeit er nicht ganz
drinnen ist hier wird sagen wir vor der
strecke bietet die hände aus zwei eins
los gehts positionswechsel gerne hätten
schon hoch mit blick nach oben dass der
kopf in der verlängerung der wirbelsäule
auch ist
genau und wem das jetzt ein bisschen zu
vieles da kann sich ganz schnell
hinlegen anrücken herz einmal vor ersten
zurückziehen und becken hoch genau das
heißt es ist die leichtere variante und
die fans immer machen was die andere ein
bisschen zu schwer ist nicht die fdp
wenn die minute zu lang wird einfach die
position wechseln ok 21 und pause
verwährt die nächste variante wir gehen
wieder in den satz nur diesmal auf die
andere seite also zuerst war auf der
linken seite jetzt nehmen die rechte
seite braucht sich nicht vor zu sagen
hat damit durchaus modern schluck
trinken wenn sie ist ja er habe es noch
15 sekunden pause nicht gibt es noch sie
einfach passt becken schön hoch lassen
unschön aus dem oberkörper herausdrücken
fünf sekunden herbert bereitmachen 21
und los geht s wieder zeit stets kurz
urheber das heißt knie sind am boden
rechter winkel zurück auch hier schauen
dass die schultern schön übereinander
gerade sein genau dahinter nissan spannt
das aus des beckens gestreckt sehr gut
zum unterschied zur letzten woche dieses
man es nicht interpretieren das heißt
mit der mit dem bewegungs wechseln
sondern diesmal ist das reine belastung
der rumpfmuskulatur zwei sekunden eine
und java pause nächste übung wiederum
das beine heben das erste bleibt kleinen
der position so wie vorher legt den
oberkörper den kopf kann man wohl egal
einsparen dann noch mal und die beine
strecken und dann hochziehen in 15
sekunden geht schon wieder los
nickel habe dir 83 auf dem seit schluss
korrigiert sich immer wieder dass leicht
nach vorne dreht das wirklich schöne die
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur reinkommt
fünf sekunden herbert spannung aufbauen
21 uhr los geht's
auch da acht jetzt bitte darauf da kopf
entweder entspannt auf der hand abgelegt
zumindestens nicht überstreckt 15
sekunden vorbei nach 10 5 sekunden und
30 pause nächste übung herbert sit ups
was gibt es dafür unterschiedliche
varianten um die intensität so steuern
die hängenden vorhalte fordert rust
genau oder seitlich am kopf genau so ist
es
je weiter die hände beim kopf oben sind
desto schwieriger wird die übung aber
das spielt was ausprobiert ein paar
sekunden noch nicht die bereit machen
für ein wechsel 21 und positionswechsel
und geht schon los
die sit ups kann natürlich wenn es
braucht ja jedes mal ganz nach oben
gehen da ist die bauchmuskulatur zu
entspannt die muskulatur oder schaut
sondern zu gewalt kommt darauf hat und
die herdorf dass sie noch voller
spannung anbau kommt dann gehen wir dann
runter statt bevor ich mich hinlegen und
dann kommen wieder hoch so habe ich viel
mehr spannung auf der bauchmuskulatur
der hobby nennt immer kleine pause
inzwischen drehen sondern da haben wir
wirklich supertein under tänzen wie es
so schön heißt das heißt eine zeit die
die bauchmuskulatur unter voller
spannung ist gerne zeit ist aus 30
sekunden vorbei nicko tours bietet die
zweite hälfte der durch nächste übung
aus dem schwimmen heraus grauer beine
das heißt in der bauchlage volle
körperspannung oberkörper kannst ablegen
herbert das heißt die hände ruhig
verschränken und den komfort mehr
ablegen dass die nackenmuskulatur mal
bis zur pause zu einer pause kommt beine
ausstrecken zehn ganz lang machen hinten
anspannen und dann einfach wechselweise
das bein heben wie beim kraulen
möglichst rasche bewegungen wechsel 30
sekunden nicht die position knie sind
gestreckt ja aber so gut wie keine
wirklich bei der übung einmal meine
nackenmuskulatur in spanien versuchen
das heißt den kopf ablegen auf den
händen
wie gesagt hintern ist angespannt knie
sind gestreckt nicht aus dem
unterschenkel schlagen
genau fünf sekunden noch 21 und 30 und
vorbei position wechseljahre
wir lernten die letzte übung im ersten
durchgang das becken heben das heißt der
oberkörper ist auf der matte abgelegt
die beine schauen im rechten winkel
jetzt dafür die etwas leichtere variante
und ich habe nur das becken nach oben
das ist wie wenn ihr beim knie dollar
anziehen würde
herbert muss mitspielen gerade hoch und
wieder runter und wieder hoch und wieder
runter genau mehr ist als drei sekunden
21 und los geht's niki andere position
mit beinen gestreckt bitte genau das
heißt deutschland die beine gestreckt
und die hebt nur das becken ganz leicht
nach oben
genau das reicht wollen ganz apart
zentimeter bewegung und wir sind perfekt
in die tiefliegenden bauchmuskulatur
tränen wo man vom training her jetzt hin
wollen möglichst ohne schwung arbeiten
sondern wirklich nur mit der muskulären
kraft in fünf sekunden seien die 30
sekunden also wieder vorbei 21 und aus
okay er hat costa rica mehr aufstehen
ein bisschen aus lockern
ein schluck trinken das ist ihr habt
schon mal die 30 sekunden variante zehn
übungen einmal gut geschafft noch meine
satzpause und dann wechsele man in einem
gleichen durchgang in einem zweiten
durchgang wieder hinein
wie geht das sagt schafft sehen sie
kunden oder dann bist du genau 32
1 und für die nici pause und auch für
euch zu hause jetzt die pause für die
die fleißig die ganze minute durch
gearbeitet haben
okay es gibt einen sportreporter sommer
letzte woche schon einmal festgestellt
ja das ist ein podcast der ist jetzt
ganz neu heraus diese diese woche jetzt
dass er in der früh mit der klare hölzl
das skispringerin ja das lohnt sich auf
alle fälle sich dieses interview vom
andreasson er mit der jahre an herrn
damit man einfach ein bisserl hinter die
kulissen blicken kann
und da man sieht und was das dort geht
beim skispringen also für mich war das
komplettes neuland aber super
interessant macht sich das anders sie
auf alle fälle aus ja und dann als
kleiner ausblick für morgen morgen
braucht man fürs training ein bisschen
zusatzgerät aber kleinigkeiten die jeder
der hahn hat das heißt ihr braucht atera
band ein sehr widerstandsband oder
wasserflaschen zwei gefüllte
wasserflaschen anbieter bietet sich gut
an hat man normalerweise zu hause
entweder mit wasser gefüllt oder auch
mit sand gefüllt wenn sibylle intensiver
werden soll
aber das sind zwei dinge die sie fürs
morgige workout für dienstag hat braucht
nicht gegangen mit der minute durch
arbeiten ist anstrengend aber immer wenn
man gut trainiert ist also das ist ganz
intensives programm und vor allem es der
zweite durchgang mit wieder ein minuten
wird dann schon richtig anstrengend ja
bei herbert hat wie gesagt die etwas
lockere variante hat macht die frage ob
es anstrengend war es geht ja genau also
wenn man wirklich gut im training steht
ist die 30 sekunden variante zu wenig
belastung auf der rumpfmuskulatur wenn
man nahezu regelmäßig trainiert wie es
wir machen dann ist natürlich die 30
varianten die sicherlich optimale
variante um vielleicht zu starten um
wieder hineinzukommen und entsprechend
eine belastung aufzubauen ok brauchen
wir eine pause
ich glaube es geht gut die
rumpfmuskulatur erholt sie eh ganz
schnell wird vorgeschlagen in 30
sekunden starten wir wieder das heißt
jeder von euch schnaps und ein schluck
aus der wasserflasche wenn dann wenn er
an durch stadt bereitet sie vor für den
zweiten durchgang in 25 sekunden legen
wir wieder los mit dem unterarm stütz
langer hebel kurzer hebel
ok ich gesagt positionen einnehmen matte
finden zehn sekunden durchschnaufen
nahmen fünf sekunden position 21 und
geht schon wieder los und weiter ganz
wichtig was nicht vergessen dürfe bei
dem ganzen ist atmen
das heißt wenn ihr in den 30 sekunden
was man theoretische ohne luftholen
schaffen würde weiter atmen und ruhig
weiteratmen kriegt einfach eure
muskulatur wesentlich mehr sauerstoff
und ist dadurch wesentlich
leistungsfähiger eine minute durch eine
art manager funktioniert leider
schwierig körperlich belasten mit einer
minuten atmen das geht seine ausbeute
hat der gak pause
dadurch wird es dann noch schwieriger 21
und 30 sekunden sind vorbei zweite
position
ja aber es hat nicht aufpasst was ist
die zweite position der holzhacker ja
das heißt wir wechseln auf die
rückenmuskulatur herbert war seiner zeit
voraus die nächste übung ist an der seit
genau zehn sekunden lang schöne position
halten nicht genau
521 und geht's los
wiederum mit ellbogen gestreckt oder
auch mit ellbogen gebeugt beide
varianten möglich wichtig ist nur dass
ich ein oberkörper heraushebt aus der
matte vom boden weg gibt es das sehr
schöne spannung da hinten ja in der
rückenmuskulatur in den rückenstrecken
hinein bekommt das ist wichtig auf das
müsste schauen hintern ist angespannt
beine sind am boden
sie konnten erste 30 sekunden hammergeil
wieder und heiztechnik herbert kurze
pause jetzt die position seit stets
genau linke seite beginnen
kurz erheben
das heißt wiederum rechter winkel
oberschenkel unterschenkel und wichtig
ist beim stützen selbst dass ihr schatz
dass der elbe unter der schulter ist und
die zweite schulte in einer ebene im weg
sagt darüber ist dass er dann irgendwann
drehung drinnen haben im rumpf 2
sekunden eine los geht's
wiederum den kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule nicht über strecken hintern
anspannen leicht nach formatieren komme
immer wieder diese position ist ganz
wichtig immer wieder zu kontrollieren
und selbst innerhalb von 30 sekunden
oder 40 sekunden mehr richtig in der
position drinnen ist der körper neigte
dazu die muskulatur herzunehmen die nur
weniger belastet ist und dann trader
bisschen richtung rücken dass wo immer
aber nicht wir wollen vorne die
belastung in der bauchmuskulatur drinnen
haben 30 sekunden erste übungs hälfte
vorbei niki habe etwas haben wir für
nächste das beine heben
genau da keines wieder gesagt eine
relativ entspannte position einnehmen
zwischen drinnen aber dass man kann
jetzt ein schlachter wenn es jetzt ja
entspannt es auf der zweiten seite zu
mindestens fünf sekunden nur zeit
position finden nicht geglaubt kannst
wechseln 21 und los geht's die beine
hoch heben in gestreckter position und
wenn das von der belastung her wie
gesagt dann zu viel wird gerne an winkel
ins bein hinein dann wird es ein
bisschen einfacher
ganz wichtig dabei ist jetzt aber dass
er nicht mit schwung nach oben reißt die
beine sondern dass wir wiederum mit
ihrer muskelkraft arbeite das heißt
lieber langsam und kontrolliert bewegen
als wir von unten schwung holen und dann
nach oben reißen
nach fünf sekunden und seil aus
und da am stütz auf der rück links das
heißt der bauch schaut nach oben ist die
nächste übung dann ja aber
sehen sie konnte nicky und dafür euch
daher die die brav durcharbeiten geist
die übung vorbei 53 und wechsel in den
stütz rücklings als variante hier könnte
natürlich auch schauen
die variante mit gestreckten händen ist
eine gute variante folgt die
beweglichkeit aus meinem schultergelenk
heraus nicht ganz auf das ist im
unterabschnitt schafft machen das mit
der gestreckten variante und wenn die
körperlich zu schwer ist das haben wir
schon gesagt dann der wechsel in die
rückenlage und das knie beziehungsweise
becken nach oben drücken
genau das sind die zwei varianten 30
sekunden rücken übung wieder vorbei
halbzeit für diejenigen die durch
arbeiten nächste übung herbert scheidt
stets rechte seite genau jetzt haben
wir's jetzt ist richtig dass ein stück
wiederum mit kurzen oder langen hebel
dann und den zehn sekunden ist die
position für die nici erledigt und für
euch die durch arbeiten das ist richtig
zam minuten im unterstützt rücklings das
ist schon wirklich anstrengender also
das muss man schon mal schaffen ok
wechsel 30 sekunden zeit stets rechte
seite langer hebel kurzer heber rotation
aus dem becken beachten dass das becken
schaut leicht nach vor es leicht nach
vorn gedreht dass sie die
brustmuskulatur seitlich im bauch
richtig davis hintern ist wie gesagt
angespannt bei kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule so schauts aus
nach fünf sekunden
auch da wieder korrigiert sich selbst
schaut auf das becken in der richtigen
position ist kontrolliert ob dahinter
angespannt ist das müsst immer wieder
selber machen ja nächste variante ist
wieder das beine heben das tier bleibt
der position becken ablegen und dann
einfach die beine wieder gestreckt oder
mit winkel nach oben ziehen
fünf sekunden bereit und los geht's
diana beine strecken und hochziehen
seitlich die bauchmuskulatur die so
jetzt jetzt spüren
sonst wird nichts weder an oder
schmerzen aber die bauchmuskulatur wenn
der muskel brennt dann ist es ein gutes
zeichen dass er arbeit und dass er
richtig und der spannung ist 321 30
sekunden sind wieder vorbei nächsten
übung die sit ups genau richtig wiederum
mit den drei varianten arme in vorhalte
arme vor der brust und arme bei den
schläfen
mit der verschärfung der übung wenn ich
nicht ganz aufgeht und nicht ganz runter
gehen sodass man bauchmuskulatur
permanent unter spannung ist sagst du
das noch mal vorher bitte genau
permanent unter spannung permanent unter
spannung
das ist dann richtig anstrengend passt
noch kurz wechsel an geht's los und da
ist er kann sein dass sich aus der
position arme bei den schläfen dreimal
in die vorhalte oder arme vor der brust
wechseln muss weil wir nicht den
bauchmuskel oder permanent unter
spannung habe ich es natürlich dann ganz
was anderes dass wir eine immer wieder
eine kurze erholungsphase habe genau
fünf sekunden 30 sekunden sind durch
zweite hälfte genau und atmen nicht
vergessen heute bei jedem sieht
appartement ja ganz wichtig die
sauerstoff muss in den körper rein damit
man leistungsfähig bleiben
gernhardt sehen sie konnten noch
wechselhaft kleine schon wieder anders
gehts grad eine 30 sekunden bzw eine
minute jetzt kann sie die
bauchmuskulatur mal ausrasten wenn mal
ein bisschen spannung heraus
jetzt arbeitet der rücken und da vor
allem der bereich des unteren rückens
gerade in dem bereich wo viele von uns
immer wieder rückenschmerzen haben von
fünf sitzen wenig bewegen das ist die
perfekte übung und da die muskulatur zu
reizen um die zu kräftigen und zu
stärken damit man dort entsprechend
leistungsfähig sein und vielleicht ein
bisschen schmerz prophylaktisch arbeiten
können
30 sekunden sind vorbei wobei alle
eingeladen erkennt natürlich gerne
weiter machen ja aber die 30 sekunden
zahlen ist vorbei es bleiben noch 20
sekunden
und wir gehen dann in die letzte übung
hinein und dann ist das werk hat wieder
vorbei 15 sekunden position wechseln
danke herr letzte übung das becken heben
genau fünf sekunden 21 uhr los geht's 30
sekunden becken heben oder eine minute
becken heben so wie es für euch von der
spannung her am besten passt wer nach 30
sekunden sagt es waren aber ausgegangen
macht weiter wir haben 32 sekunden
möglich ja
das becken einfach vom boden abheben
reicht voll und ganz aus ich brauche die
einer kerze hoch gehen wie man es von
den kindern vielleicht noch ganz am
anfang nur hochheben und das ist gut 30
sekunden sind durch festnahme eine
chance das drauf bleibt jetzt kann jeder
name drauf bleiben weil wie gesagt
letzte übung des heutigen workouts 15
sekunden
es ist es sogleich oft noch zehn letzten
drei sekunden 21 und walker ist vorbei
ja gut gemacht leute perfekt trainiert
zu hause zweiter also erstes workout
zweite woche ist erledigt wir haben als
kleine überraschung für euch am mittwoch
und am freitag jeweils einen
leistungssportler mit dabei der einen
kleinen einblick in sein
trainingsprogramm geben wird ja das
heißt doch einmal zwei neue gesichter
mit drinnen und wie gesagt morgen noch
einmal die erinnerung er braucht es für
das workout entsprechend ein resistance
band das heißt ein widerstandsband
seiser thera band black rock band war es
auch immer und oder zwei wasserflaschen
am besten gefüllt mit wasser oder sand
damit ihr das morgige kraft ausdauer
werk hat richtig intensiv und soll
mitmachen können von meiner seite von
unserer seite her weiß dass wir wünschen
euch noch einen schönen tag und sehen
uns morgen um 10 uhr 30 wieder
dankeschön und bis morgen